uh let's see if it plays out that way
saint vs chanel incoming chanel probably
rocking the
eliza yes it is yep
all right genuine gaming saint versus
uh rox gaming's uh eliza uh chanel
eliza
yeah the lies is crazy from him and it's
so good the the low dive kicks
uh and just the pressure he creates out
of that right uh but you saw jdcr
adapted to it i did really good on that
uh infinite stage against her so we'll
see how things get out here obviously
staying jdcr gives you big time training
partners partners on echo box teammates
i should say oh man the jump back dive
counter hit
yeah both just kind of
shocking for position right now
oh here we go saints coming in
ah doesn't get the punish there
[Music]
oh
yeah power crush through that's a good
choice
that's a great choice if you have a
quick solid power crush against a
character like eliza is doing dive kicks
all day
uh yeah that's not a mattress you know
you can only lose to throws and loads
and she's coming down airborne just
going to armor through it
[Music]
finishing the string this time full bar
you can make something happen with it
solid lead here around yeah
use the position with the wall there too
saint with a big life deficit though
going in down forward to threes using
that deceptive range
oh burns a bar
keeps the pressure up no saint doesn't
fight
oh okay box at this time
chanel just yeah
staying back
saint huge life deficit nine seconds at
the clock he has to do something
oh he's gonna sleep already it's too
early to sleep oh he's gonna do it again
oh
that hits grounded
but not like in the combo's animation
yeah if he had hit a button
yeah he slept
he slept really early there i thought it
wasn't going to work
here's the down four two
oh okay
oh
all right this type of state that comes
out early oh man okay not the best punch
there
but full meter personnel not even going
to matter that round is all same four
fight
this is that's the three still first
game
chanel with full bar and the knockdown
situation
oh
oh let's get the up
saint harassing all day
burns oh get out of here
the unblockable yes
saint with rage now
he does have a round b he might be yeah
he can afford to do something kind of
crazy but plus frames and yeah this goes
low chanel takes it takes that round
ties it up
final round
nearly full barcelona's a great
situation what an option get out of here
hell i have that scouted
that's four one plus you have a low pair
from chanel here though yeah answering
back five foot combo to the wall
dive kick pressure here no sir
hit the ex oh
keeps about the wall
saint
god i'll get the wall flat okay
yeah this is not going to kill
yeah
oh good block
double rage
50 50 stuff
that wasn't in dxdp i don't know what he
did then
he spent bar on something but it wasn't
the right choice ex dp there should have
worked i'm pretty sure
uh somebody can confirm the frame rate
on that later i think that was down
forward three into downpour one from
saint
uh but i don't know yeah could have been
an accidental input maybe he wanted the
dp got a ex fireball instead yeah uh
regardless though
uh not the right choice same get in that
first game
damn
that was good
saints on a tear it's
with kanru of all characters right i
mean we we're in a tournament here with
you know the [ __ ] rums and the lydia
that came out and the pieces and saint
just you know here with uh the lone gone
here just uh making it work and uh he's
gone
realized yeah yeah and uh you know i
mean there are there aren't a million
guns either i mean they're uh
you know there could even be some
character familiar unfamiliarity uh you
know the advantages of playing a
character like that so um but uh but
yeah i mean he's been making it work
yeah the thing about genry though like
the character hasn't really changed a
whole lot like he's got some new stance
options but the core gantry stuff is
still the core stuff and we do get a
character swap from chanel here going to
the zafina pick here
uh this one should be interesting i mean
i don't feel like eliza was necessarily
a bad matchup i think saint showed that
he's very prepared for it right
uh so let's see if chanel's zafina is
ready to go right he's got to switch
gears real fast here
uh yeah down here
one of the seconds already here switched
pretty quick there
yeah just everything working for chanel
and state's gonna have to
adapt here push his way out just a
little hug switch his sides
and yeah and even even still oh
all right good round start from saint
here
pretty good 50 percent here
harassing away
all right all right
yeah round four maybe turning things
around here putting himself on the board
in the second game
i feel like this is like tournament
scene too
when saint is coming from behind like
he's just like stepping down like nah
it's not over like it doesn't matter if
you have too much he'll find a way it is
terrifying
yeah
okay here we go spring kick get some
breeding room chanel oh gosh
this ain't looking really comfortable
right now
ah the squid
squid game
oh no
yeah saint just slowing it down with a
slight life lead here i'm running out
though
punish that
for once oh boy oh scary
chanelle definitely bell's got really
basic mode
yeah
and 10 seconds you know gotta make
something happen
saint here just
staying back he's driving scary
oh
and this
is gonna take the game for chanel tying
it up 1-1
wow yeah that was that was tense that
was tense i mean i was saying the race
drive is so scary here in that situation
right and so he forced the situation
where there's not enough time he's got
to make one choice and it seems like all
right well it's probably a rage drive so
i better stand guard and then yeah slow
low got your feet yeah uh yeah
yeah
yeah that was that's crazy that was a
choice
yeah that was very that was very
intentional that was like yeah i know
you you think i'm you know we all were
thinking waiting for that and uh yeah
chanel
just yeah question out there
yeah well we're going to go down
with the final game
and yeah
it's a good choice with character series
it was looking really good for my first
option but same you know as i mentioned
he's the kind of player that doesn't
give up after being down two rounds and
he's made the adjustments already uh so
going to the next game i feel like it's
saying shouldn't switch characters i
feel like they should be harmless
yeah you know he saw what the subpoena
has to offer uh it's obviously gonna
have a little bit extra in game two but
at the same time his gamryu he
understands what he needs to do with it
i think uh the the crazy thing for me in
this masterpiece it's still that down
for three usage right because it seems
like he kind of goes rounds where he
turns it off and he turns it back on
again so it's really curious because
even if he has low pair he's like all
right you got a little prayer well i
better do it again
like he just doesn't he doesn't stop
he's like dory it's still part of my
game plan it's not going anywhere
yeah yeah i mean that that's that's part
of the mind games too though right i
mean you know do to stop doing the thing
that's
uh that was working because they counted
it once like you know that's the obvious
thing to do right so um yeah you got to
mix it up and you know that explains the
hell sweeps that people do uh even after
they get blocked and punished and they
do it again immediately right
all right we're going into the final
game here
chanel vs saint
hey that one plus two from sabina so
good too
uh oh broadway time hey hey
try for that that was such a good time
yeah
that was wonderful
and he waited for the backswing blow to
come back before he swung too
yeah otherwise it would have whipped up
a nice internal thing
i believe 11.
yeah very fast move or maybe ten yeah
oh damn the down four twos yeah we
haven't seen that
in this game
got the massage what's the mix up
oh man just one down four three and then
the downward one makes
yeah this is definitely that everything
is working saint gandu that we've seen
before
tied up in rounds though
damn her back that gets out of the
downpour three down four three
yeah oh look at this just like that see
that yeah
and that's exactly what he's winning he
was setting him up for that he did it
three times if you go back and watch
that round that was so good yeah that
way i know you can get out of here
just like that
now fight
get it out of the way start
get out of here
get to the wall mm-hmm
interesting look out
oh my god i got lows too
damn he ducked after the downpour too
punish that oh
no
he's still facing down for that no
punishes they're looking for the jabs
coming after there's nothing coming
after
yeah
oh there they came in a second it still
caught him oh
right there at that moment
the predictable thing would be to just
like okay time to climb up and be
conservative right and i think saint
just knew like i'm gonna go in right now
and uh end it right here oh yeah you
know before you know i don't want this
extend any further and he was able to uh
uh just end it right there and
uh yeah just uh uh taking out chanel